so we've got some plans. Um,
let me briefly start of the stream go
through what I'm thinking about.
So, first of all,
I got to stop looking at Twitter.
Uh Twitter is driving me nuts and
it's mostly because now in addition to
um Carpathy,
we've got
another person who I have at least a
good amount of respect for
with the same sort of thing on the new
models.
So
I really don't think this is going to be
the case, man. like there's no way the
models are remotely that good. I think
everyone's looking for just an easy way
to move faster when there isn't one.
Um,
the way to move faster has always been
by moving slower, paradoxically enough.
So, here's the plan. The stream on this
is going to be maybe tomorrow, maybe the
day after. It'll be pretty soon. I'm
going to have to set a couple things up
for it. Um these are the full details.
You can read this here. Welcome a light.
Um but I'll give you a few more details
on stream uh for the early joiners here
as to what this is going to be. The task
I have in mind.
I'm only going to say this once because
um this is just a quick preview for the
uh the live stream. It's this boss. It's
kind of like the most iconic raid boss
from um old school. And I'm thinking I
just implement this one fight. Should be
about a thousand lines. Um it's got some
interesting mechanics to it and it would
be a pretty cool environment for RL. So
I could implement a version of this
myself. I think in about a good weekend.
So, we're going to see if I can make
more progress in a day than I would have
made myself uh with whatever model we
end up using. It's going to be C. It's
got to be high perf. It's a real task.
We're not going to like, oh, you know,
try a web slop or some gross Python
thing like that's not useful. Um,
I am going to be listening to chat on
like, hey, you're using it wrong. This
is going to be a genuine attempt.
All right,
code quality still has to be good. If it
produces crap code, it produces crap
code. It will have plenty of examples of
good code. All right, so that's not
going to be a bottleneck.
And uh if I need to do something other
than opus for people to take it
seriously, let me know. But from what
I've seen, people are mostly up on opus.
So that's probably what it's going to
be.
Now, that's not what we're going to do
today, though. This is going to be
either tomorrow or the day after
depending how much progress I make
today. And then after that, I probably
have to take a couple days off streaming
in order to catch up on some client
work. Uh what we're going to do today is
something substantially harder. Yeah.
And what I want to do is I want to get
uh our breakout environment
actually solving faster than current
state-of-the-art. So I believe it was
either 23 or 27 seconds in puffer 3 was
the fastest we could solve breakout on a
single 5090.
In order to make this better, uh what we
have to do today is we have to get
cudggraphs working properly and
numerically matched and most likely some
of the kernels
and then this will be sort of enough
that we have the whole end to end and
the rest of 40 if we can do that will be
more minor a bunch of experiments. Uh I
it's obviously it's like super hardcoded
right now. So I've got to make it work
with multiple environments. I got to
figure out interfaces. There's lots of
that other stuff, but I think this is
the core hard thing right now. Yeah.
So, let me show you where we left off.
Okay, so this is where we left it if I
recall.
Now we need to have
we need to figure this thing out with
CUDA graphs if I recall right.
Yeah, because we have these this index
copy thing.
I think
I can just do this outside of the CUDA
graphs, right?
Cuz like
Yeah, ratio doesn't get used in a loop
here. I think I can literally I don't
know why I didn't think of this last
night.
Kind of shows you I have to do stuff
fresh.
Uh this is rollout. So I put this in the
wrong function.
Temp train index. Perfect. So
right here
Um, and the thing is this has ratio and
new value, right?
ratio and new value. So I think we need
ratio out and new value out or
something. We need some extra buffer
here.
Puffer graph
graph ratio
and graph new value.
Oh, wait. I see new value right there.
MB ratio train new value. Okay, cool.
I can think I just do it like this. It's
an output
train ratio.
Oh, wait. MB graph train.
This gets allocated somewhere, doesn't
it? Yeah.
And then what we do is we copy this
output.
And where's new value?
New value.
New value and input. No, it's right
here.
And new value is right here.
So what we're basically trying to do
here there are a couple things that are
like dynamic and they need to be static
for cuda graphs.
The two things we need today are we need
to get the graphs
working nicely
um with the full loss
and then we got to start getting the
kernels to
Yeah. So, I will do this type of thing
on stream, right? This is like the main
prompt file, right?
This is funny. Yeah, honestly, I I
agree.
I also remember having read that code.
Like
I think that's the only passable chunk
of Java code I've ever seen was the
Minecraft source.
Like Java is a freaking terrible
language, but that guy made it almost
seem okay.
Did this not compile then? I'm confused.
It should be faster. Crude graphs is on.
Well, that's weird.
Zero and started training,
Yeah. Okay. So, let's see what the heck
happened here.
Graph set to true. Set this to false.
This should be recovering original PF.
I swear whenever you do anything about
language models, you get these comments
that just do not make any sense.
Whatever.
All right. So, here we go. Look, this
gets us
750. This is believe the match per
right. It's a little low.
And then cuda grass through.
It's faster, though not much faster.
Oddly enough,
it goes to zero temporarily,
which is very weird.
let's just rule out the loss maybe real
quick.
Yeah, let's rule out the loss function
because pretty easy to do this, right?
We just do like um
this
What is missing in 40? A lot, man. A lot
is still missing.
Like this is essentially what I'm doing
now is this is um a very hacky hardcoded
version of just trying to get it to run
on Breakout first. But like all the hard
tech problems will be solved with this
uh with this version. So once I get
breakout to solve at 10 million steps
per second, everything else is
essentially just going to be like polish
and design and some interfaces and more
minor things.
So, a lot is missing uh in terms of the
content, but in terms of the difficulty,
like a lot of the hard stuff is just
right here. What you're seeing
Okay. So
with CUDA graphs is that on?
Yeah. CUDA graphs on except for the fuse
loss.
Uh we solve.
So the only graph that's bad is
is this one.
So this replay forward somehow.
Happy new year from [clears throat] HK.
Thank you. Happy New Year from America.
We still have uh 12 hours or so left in
the year
and uh I intend to use them to get state
of the art solve time on breakout. That
would be good.
Okay. So, I mean this is the loss right
here, right?
Is this just as far as the vibe coder? I
don't know. You tell me. How are the
vibes here?
The vibes here are currently like, "Fuck
you, Cudigraphs."
Interesting that the graphing the
graphing op itself is what fails on
this.
Oh, you know what? I wonder
index copy.
You get graph train ratio graph train
new value right
train temp index.
So this doesn't actually get reserved
anyways.
So let's just replace this with index
and then we'll get rid of this temp
train index and we'll see if I'm using
this anywhere by mistake.
Like you can't graph this.
You can't do um like variable index
selections
with cuda graphs. Like everything has to
be static shapes, static indices for
cudigraph to play nice.
Uh, I don't need this extra call here.
Thank you very much.
Realistically, there are a lot of places
this could be messed up, though. I think
I'll start with these indices.
Like this is the biggest graph, right?
Yeah. So you see here it's very uh
wait it's very odd like it starts
learning after a while but it has zero
for like zero score for for a bit as
well.
So let's see what uh what ops get
graphed.
Why do you have subscriptions donations
turned off?
Uh
I forgot if I ever applied for um what's
the thing before partner? I think I was
eligible. I mean either way, Benjamin, I
don't need the money from um viewers.
I stream this for fun and show uh and to
get people interested into the project.
Um all this stuff is free and open
source, but there's a company as well.
So uh we monetize enterprise clients,
not viewers.
I kind of want everything to just be
free for the community.
How is it unsupported in Wait, how is it
unsupported? It's C and Python. What do
you mean? How is it unsupported?
Oh, the indexing. So, it's because
you're doing cudigraph. So, cudigraph
replays a very like it replays the exact
operations that you trace in the same
memory addresses.
So, it's kind of not actually CN Python.
It's just pure CUDA ops
starring. Any other way you can support
your work? Of course, get involved with
development, you know. Um, most of these
projects here, let me show you this. So,
the stuff I'm doing right now is
obviously a total pain in the ass,
right? Uh, but most of the development
and most of what makes Puffer Lib what
it is doesn't require you to do that.
Uh, most of these environments here are
by contributors. And you would be
surprised by what environments end up
being useful for research. You know,
lately 2048 ended up being tremendously
helpful for research. We have a whole
bunch of new stuff we can do on this. We
have a project on mazes in the works
that's tremendously useful. Um, there's
an Overcooked PR that I plan to merge in
uh pretty soon as well. Like lots and
lots of these environments are nice. On
the algo side, like there's always
little bits of research to be done here
and there around as well. There's always
help with experiments and testing. It's
pretty much just getting involved with
the open source side. I mean, this is an
effort to push the field forward and um
there are a lot of places that we could
use help for that depending on your
skill set.
Somebody asked why Puffer is not working
on Windows. We don't officially support
Windows. It should work on WSL.
Thanks for streaming. Yeah, I have fun
doing it, too. Hyper.
All right. Do we see any weird
operations here?
Did I forget and do like some weird
indexing?
I don't see anything.
I mean, obviously, we have the forward
pass.
Thanks, Ben.
Uh
oh.
Yeah, we can't graph this. Duh. Right.
No, wait. Can we?
Advantage normalize mean advantage
normalize standard deviation.
Can we not graph that? We can, right?
That's just that hurts the kernel. That
shouldn't hurt graphing.
Had fun with puffer pong. Yeah, puffer
pong is like the simplest simplest task
I think when you're doing algorithm
stuff. The reason I use breakout so
often is breakout is the simplest task
where if something works on breakout, it
probably is useful elsewhere.
How do you measure if an NV is good for
research? Uh well, it has some
interesting and unexpected property,
right? So with 2048,
it just ended up being way harder of an
environment than expected and it scaled
quite well. So you got these very nice
log linear training curves where you
would get better and better policies
with more compute. So like you know it's
a task that you can't just full solve
instantly. Uh there's actually a pretty
high skill ceiling of play for such a
simple end. You can run it quite fast.
It's got a lot of properties that you
would like to have.
I mean other environments can be like
if you can demonstrate in an environment
like some interesting learnable property
that's also cool. We have a few projects
in exploration that are going to have
custom MS that demonstrate like a
specific new learned thing.
There really are just a lot of ways to
help and you know if you have the uh the
mind for it there probably environments
that can be implemented in two to 300
lines that would be quite useful to
research
if you're not as experienced on the
research side to like know what's good
and what isn't though. I mean just
having more ends in more domains is
always useful.
Thoughts on Golang?
Um, it seems fine, I suppose, better
than a lot of other stuff. Um, I don't
really have a use for it though in our
stuff. Roger. Like I can just write say
I really don't need a lot of the things
that other languages give me.
Of
course, I say that I'm looking at Torch
C++, which is just awful.
But when I'm writing C, I'm generally
I'm generally pretty relaxed.
Okay, I don't see anything weird in this
where
I'd be breaking cudographs.
So,
could it be here?
Like, is this messed up somewhere?
But it's weird because it can't be like
it can't be very messed up because it
does learn, right?
Oh, you know what? I bet I know what it
is. You know, I bet I know. I bet you I
know what it is.
it's like just let a man write some CN
peace.
It's just such a simple language.
Everything is just effortlessly fast and
there aren't a million dumb tools to
think about that you don't actually
need.
moral theory CTDE actually means um so
Simeon most of the stuff in moral papers
just doesn't work
is kind of the thing that's like fine
there are a few ways to implement it um
one is just that the value function uh
takes the observations of all the agents
So you know the value function has more
information than the agent policy, but
you don't need the value function to
actually execute the agents. So you can
train it centralized, but then execute
it decentralized, if that makes sense,
because you're training it with this
global value function, but then you
don't need the value function for
inference.
That one actually does apparently work.
I haven't messed with that too much.
Like the thing about multi-agent is that
the most effective thing has just been
running the single agent algorithm on
the multi-agent environments and it
actually works. Um,
and I think I'm one of the people more
qualified to say that as well given that
I did massively multi-agent RL for my
old PhD.
A lot of the multi- aent uh custom
algorithm lead is just very low quality.
to see the TypeScript date. You're using
TypeScript on back end. What are you
doing
and use? I'm begging you use a real
language.
Honestly, I haven't used Go, but from
what I've seen, it seems like fine.
go or Zigg or whatever. If you want
something that isn't just straight C,
they seem fine.
Like I could see the argument for C like
C but with a slightly larger standard
library. And then there are a few bits
of polish that I would want, but um most
of the time like the languages they come
up with a bunch of fancy stuff I don't
want and don't actually fix the stuff I
that does need to be fixed.
I know there are a couple things in C
that just like absolutely should not
compile that do and then there are a
couple things that don't compile but
should
stuff like that.
progress in research
and techniques though. Honestly, just
getting good at engineering man. Most
research is blocked by the engineering
being bad.
Gang likes difficult learning curve to
be good. C does not have a difficult
learning curve at all to be good though.
That's the misconception.
There's like
there's like you can just write basic
for loops and if statements and
functions with like single pointers and
that's it. Like I was as comfortable in
C as I was in Python within three weeks.
I think less than three weeks
like you need to be you do need to be
told that an address sanitizer exists
and you need to use it. That's the main
thing.
lowkey confused why their code works.
That sounds like Marl.
Nobody switch over to it. Well, I mean,
Liberty, sometimes good ideas do get
overlooked. Um, but the thing is there's
just so much noise in research. You
can't assume that something works
because it's published.
Like until there's good simple code
that's been evaluated on a variety of
scenarios,
it's just very difficult to say. Happy
New Year Eve to you as well.
Oh, this epoch is not getting
incremented.
Wait, no, you dummy. This is correct.
Puffer epoch incremented outside of the
loop. Okay.
Anything like that in here?
No.
Max gradorm.
Max Bradorm gets set up top, right?
because this is a co. Oh yeah, that's
the other thing. Um,
yeah, these co-ops need to get set up
top, but I think I do set them up top.
Oh, you know what this is? I bet it's
the um I bet you it's the learning rate
not working.
Would that do it? like
learning rate not getting a yield.
I could see that doing it right.
Uh yeah, let's go check that real quick.
Let's go check that.
So the annoying thing right with um CUDA
graphs is any of your constants the
constants just get hardcoded into the
program and if you change the constant
they don't actually get updated in the
CUDA graph.
So
I believe what we need to do is we need
to change learning rate to be a tensor,
right?
Which is annoying because that's not how
their optimizers usually work.
But I don't actually really care if this
looks like a normal torch optimizer.
Hey, that guy
We're probably going to try your tan,
your die can, whatever the heck it is
thing later today
once I get the other stuff to work.
Does it work? Well,
all of your Opus questions are going to
be answered on one stream.
I made this announcement already and I I
added a followup to it today. Okay,
look, these are the details. I'm going
to do a stream. It's probably going to
be either tomorrow or the day after.
I'm going to give it a full day
and we will see if y'all are smoking
copium or not on the models.
I suspect there's a lot of smoking
copium.
Yeah, I actually uh that guy this is one
of those cases where I would believe
that a simpler thing would work. Like
the RMS norm thing is just straight up a
case of scientists having come up with
something with zero regard to whether
it's fast
Yeah. Well, I think it's just that like
they tried it on a bigger model and like
it made it a bit slower and it did
better in steps. So, they just published
the graph and that's you call it a day.
You never bother to like, well, if we
run this on a small model, oh wow,
that's really slow. You know, I've
talked to several research and they
didn't even know that their models were
that slow because of norms.
That's kind of silly.
Explicit. Move on.
What the heck?
major whims and L's of the year. Well,
the major L of the year was starting it
off by nearly dying of pneumonia.
Um,
and losing 18 pounds of muscle
and basically like being pretty fat as a
result of medical grade catabolic
steroids to keep me alive. That kind of
sucked.
And uh, the major W's of this year was
we made the field of RL 10x faster. We
made major algorithmic breakthroughs. We
scaled the company from very little to
actually pretty respectable revenue and
profitable. Um, and I got myself back
into shape. I just did uh what was it on
a treadmill, but still like 724ish pace,
5K yesterday. Pretty much got all my
strength back as well. So, yeah, pretty
good year. First higher.
Yeah, that's good.
Oh yeah, Spencer like started working.
Yeah, that's like Huh. That is only a
year.
Yeah, that's good.
What is norm here? Norm is um
there's this RMS norm layer. It's just
standard RMS norm layer that we have to
use and it's slow for small models.
Does anybody understand what the heck
C++ mess I'm looking at? Can I just add
a torch tensor here for the learning
rate? The learning rate has to be a
tensor. It can't be um uh the learning
rate has to be a tensor. It cannot be a
uh a float or double.
Can I just stick it here? Will this be
fine? I have no idea what this mess of
C++ is I'm looking at.
Yeah.
But oh yeah, that guy. So that guy's
also the big runner. I did was it 8.1
miles per hour on the treadmill
yesterday, which is I think 724 pace. I
think I could push it a little more as
well.
It feels like cheating though on the
treadmill. It feels like much much
easier.
There's a bounce back.
Treadmill is cheating. Yeah, I figured.
I did do like a 730 something though on
mostly wood chips um that are way harder
than rope. So
three up.
Still can't run. That sucks.
I didn't I didn't do four plates again
yesterday. I also pulled I think I
pulled like 380 for two yesterday.
The strength is still back.
Is good. We'll see what I do this year.
I have to come up with a couple new
fitness goals.
Let me come in here.
I actually do not know what I'm This is
a I mean, this is like a stupid
question, right?
I like I literally just don't know what
I'm looking at with this. It's just what
is this C? Like what is this language?
this side. See, I don't like that
either.
Wait, where is this? Oh, here. Right.
Torch check.
Yeah,
it's fine. See, I heal.
Okay.
And I can just get rid of this auto LR,
right?
Initializer list, but torch checked.
Yeah, I honestly I don't think I'm going
to keep I don't think I'm going to keep
my code the way that Torch does it in
Puffer, honestly, because like the way
that Torch does their code. I guess
technically I could try to contribute
chunks of it back, but like the Torch
C++ is so bad. It's just not worth
following the way that they do stuff.
I'd rather just simplify it a whole
bunch
and have it be way shorter.
I don't have to be good at C++ to
understand that there's more code than
there should be,
you know.
term AGI makes no sense as a concept.
Here's my definition of AGI. I wrote
this article a while ago and my
definition's been consistent since 2018.
It's funny that the longer this goes on,
like the more my definition makes starts
making sense compared to everyone
else's, which is kind of a fail,
[laughter]
you know, Oh,
Yeah, Puffer Drive 2 is really awesome.
Um, y'all should definitely look at
that. So, this was our biggest academic
collaboration.
You see,
there's a nice video on it.
It's actually being used now in
industry.
It's funny that his So, it actually
isn't bad.
What the heck?
Move on. Oh.
over this.
We're just going to do it quick.
2048 with lesser word shaping and ops.
See how it goes.
Looks like human language is
controlling.
I mean the funny thing Brad is like my
definition is kind of fine cuz my AGI
definition is like we'll know it when we
see it cuz it'll look like literal
magic. Until then shut up you yappers
and build it,
Hey Jess, we're currently trying to make
cudographs work
um with well we're trying to make
cudigraphs work correctly so that we can
reproduce the breakout solve and have it
be super fast.
This is a humanoid ones. Oh, wait. What?
What's one of these under?
Is this offline? No.
Online.
Were these the humanoid ones?
Or am I thinking of something else?
Wait, has Carla.
Oh, 2024. This is
D4 R.
[snorts]
Yeah, offline RL is not RL
simply put
models can write C markdowns
describe I will write proper specs man
I'm not going to like I'm not going to
just write like build end plus right but
like it seems I don't know for some
reason people seem to think that like
writing a spec is such a hard thing to
do. Like you think if I can't write the
end for myself, like if I can write the
end for myself, you think I can't figure
out how to write a spec. There's
literally no skill required to do that.
Like I will do it properly. I still
think it's going to fail though.
Or at least it's going to like produce a
bunch of crap that's going to be more
effort for me to debug and fix and be
more frustrating than just doing it
myself.
Okay, these can't be called get initial.
Well, R. We're going to
which is gross. We'll fix this stuff
later.
This can be fine. This is fine,
actually. Yeah, this just needs to
change the name.
that you kind of negate if you were to
use Unreal Engine.
Uh there will be an Unreal Engine when a
company asks us to do it and there's an
official contract.
like I pretty much I have like this
clear map of what I need to do for RL to
be where it needs to be and any
deviation to that uh is going to be done
under professional work because then at
the very least it does benefit the real
road map of you know the rest of what
needs to be done for RL by funding
Okay. So, this is the same as it was
before. Doesn't work. Um,
This might be it. It's pretty much I
just don't think that um learning rate
and nailing gets applied correctly when
um yeah learning rate and nailing is not
getting applied when we're doing
cudographs because
when you're applying the update the
learning rates are taken as a constant
and constants don't get updated in place
um when you cuda graph everything has to
be a tensor
quantum computing I have no idea about
quantum man.
It seems like
okay if you think of like NFTTS and web
3 as the [ __ ] terms where there's
actually nothing behind them for the
most part. So quantum is like the
[ __ ] term where there is something
actually there but I have no idea what.
But everybody just says quantum this,
quantum that. I started taking like um a
little bit of actual quantum physics and
it was incredibly interesting
but it's an area where you actually need
quite a bit of knowledge to like think
about
you need quite a bit of knowledge to
actually speak intelligently about it.
It's not something that's like casually
friendly.
See, I don't think it is just imagine 10
billion steps per second. It's like
specific types of things you can solve
potentially with it. I don't know. It's
very difficult for me to like
conceptualize
overight marketing even. Yeah, it's a
pain.
I mean, the thing is you can just ignore
it and build real stuff. Like that's the
nice thing. You can't really with
language models because they're too big.
But in RL you totally cannot
be applied to a zero dimensional tensor.
Okay.
We can build quite a lot at the moment.
We can build quite a lot.
If I can just get this to run 10 mil,
it' be nice.
And what I really want to have with this
update is I want to have full
understanding of like where our computes
getting spent and how efficient we are.
Man, this is still off.
Really?
Like it shouldn't go to zero at the
start.
adding flops to the womb charts. though
I can definitely add it. Um
I I don't know if there's a no overhead
way to compute it. I guess we could run
it once through the net. So that guy the
problem is like you could technically
switch to sweeps charts to be in flops,
but I thought about it and it's actually
not particularly relevant because um it
gives you a wrong impression of scaling.
Like what matters is that you have a
well optimized implementation of your
nets at various sizes and then what
matters is wall clock from there
because you know it matters how fast you
can actually solve the problem not how
fast you could solve the problem if
there were zero overhead with
everything.
It would be nice if we could get like an
upper bound. Hey, if our implementation
were perfect, this is how fast it would
be. But you can't compute that just by
dividing flops, right? you actually need
to do a pretty sophisticated estimate of
like what is the minimum realistic
memory uh overhead that you would have
etc etc
why using muon does QR not bottlenecks
small nets so uh it can but we have
large batches and first of all it's not
a QR right it's um unless that's part of
the new uh of the was it Newton Schles
iteration
but event essentially You amortize the
cost over a 32,000 mini batch or
whatever. And yes, you get way better
convergence. We've tested it's a massive
generational difference. Be right back.
Give me one minute. All right. resting
real quick.
Yep.
Flops on X-axis so I can align against
other folks. Um I think it's it might be
useful for tracking some insights, but
it's also quite misleading. That guy, I
mean, if you could show a scaling law
works in pure flops, that would be
really interesting.
There's quite a bit of experimental work
that could be done around puffer with
this. I've also been thinking about um
I've been thinking about like small
networks that are more flop efficient.
So like let's say that you could get
that same 130 microscond forward pass,
but you could actually be using your
flops effectively.
It's probably going to be something like
iterated computation with the same small
weight matrix or something.
Are we able to run sweep using
distributed? Uh yes, that will be a
thing on 40 oj. We have it implemented
already. You don't use uh multiple GPUs
per experiment, but you do use like all
the GPUs on a box to run different
experiments at the same time and it's
like done for you.
Yeah.
In general, I think that what needs to
happen is we need to have a lot more of
these architecture chunks. Like they
need to be designed by people who
understand the hardware to some level
who have like written a piece of
efficient code ever. Um because
otherwise what happens it's researchers
who just do not understand anything
about computational efficiency just like
throwing ops at the wall until they do
better in terms of steps with like no
understanding of how these ops are fast
or slow or can they meet uh can they be
made fast with custom kernels right like
it's just a bad can I grab that from a
branch would like to use it in chess uh
sure it's on it's just a small chunk of
code in puffl on forj. It might even be
I think there might even be like a
sweeps branch.
It does let you hook into the same sweep
object with all the GPUs.
There are a couple different modes of
it.
Okay, Phil LR here.
Uh,
what's going on here? Like,
how do I test this?
It's not even on the right device, is
it?
Okay. So, this is not even on the right
device.
Uh,
Why isn't CPU low type? Oh, cuz you're
dumb and you just did
a CPU.
I actually don't know what that does.
Presumably it's a CUDA graph. It only
traces GPU offs
I would assume.
So probably it's like converting it.
Oh, look at that.
That's better, right?
Oho,
look at that folks.
That is correctly cudggraphed
training.
And that's a solve. About 850ish is
considered. I consider that close enough
to solve. Right.
Okay. So, uh we can make a quick commit
for practic.
How to get
the mindset to unlearn something and
think you never learned that before.
Start fresh with an open mind. So, it's
very difficult and I'm somewhat guilty
of like giving this advice.
Well, I'm giving this advice as strongly
as I am because I know how hard it would
be for me to take it. Um, because I've
got a very large ego around a lot of my
work. But you essentially you have to be
open to the fact that the way that
you've been doing stuff for many years
might just be stupid and wrong. And it's
not necessarily because you're just
stupid. It's because like stuff is just
taught in a way that's completely stupid
and you were exposed to it at a time
when you were very impressionable and it
can be completely wrong. And that's just
the case with how a lot of programming
is taught.
So, you have to be open to the idea that
basically like the way you've been doing
stuff for a long time might be
completely wrong. Um, you still know
something that's going to allow you to
learn much quicker than if you were
starting from scratch. It's not like
you've learned literally nothing, but
you are going to have to spend some time
like completely rewiring the way that
you do things. And it's going to be
quite painful and it's going to be
somewhat humiliating for a little bit,
but then like after a week or two,
you're going to be so much happier
because you're going to be able to do
stuff uh so fast that would have taken
you months before and it's going to be
so easy. So that's pretty much what it
is.
Like I've honestly I've become probably
twice as good of a programmer the year
after my PhD and then this next like
this past year I've probably gotten
twice as good uh each year. So I'm
probably four times better than I was
finishing my PhD. You know at the end of
my PhD I'd written Python for 10 years.
Like yeah I'd spent a lot of time
thinking about how do I write good code?
How do I build stuff? How do I architect
things? So, I had like a lot of concepts
in my head, but they were kind of
arranged in all the wrong order.
When I started to eat healthy,
surprisingly, let me think.
I mean, diet has probably been like,
well, I guess it depends where you start
off. Um, diet has only been maybe third
or fourth most important thing for me.
But then again, the thing is with me,
like I if I just eat whatever I want,
I'll lose weight by default. So, it's a
little different if you're the opposite.
Um because I kind of need the calories.
project is on the front page. No, it
isn't. Dude,
you're just screwing with me.
Biggest technical skill. Nah, it is.
Link it.
Kung's post. Really?
Oh,
I thought you were screwing with me.
That's cool.
Well, it's not getting number one with
that top one, but
That thing is like such a bad deal.
Like why would I ever do that?
It's not meant for people in my position
though to be fair. It's meant for like
out of undergrad or whatever
who has all the equity in pover right
now.
Well, there's no it's bootstrap, dude.
We don't have investors.
It's actually very nice because that
means that I have the full pool of
equity um to split up among people who
actually meaningfully contribute to the
project.
has to be on the professional side of
force as well.
When are you going to check Opus? Waited
for a week for this day. Not today, man.
I told you it's on the post. It says
tomorrow or the day after most likely.
I'm doing CUDA stuff though. I mean, we
have cool dev here every day. I stream
it, but I'm not going to like switch up
my entire like I'm not going to let Opus
touch this thing, right? He'll make a
mess.
I was joking about YC. Yeah,
just cross things out you disagree with
in the contract
in initial.
I mean, giving them a chunk of equity
for basically no money is kind of the
main one.
Opus 45 is really good. I will determine
that for myself. Look, if you think it's
good, then join the stream. Either it's
going to be tomorrow or the day after,
right? I'll announce it on X. Join the
stream and make sure I'm not using it
wrong. Okay, that's what you can do.
I'll take equity. Thank you. Got to work
on our professional stuff.
Ideally, helping us to get and sign
bigger contracts as well.
Who do I want? I I don't have anyone
that I want, dude.
Like
This is not like some bluff or some me
playing my cards close to my chest or
some [ __ ] Like, I'm genuinely just
having a good time doing this and want
to keep doing it.
Not whining about LM calling NFTTS.
Um because he's a good dev and the LMS
are actually [ __ ] and people are
shilling them and they suck
[laughter] like Again,
if you disagree with this take, I said
I'm going to be doing a full day stream
later this week. You're free to join in
and like make sure I'm using everything
correct and see if I can actually get
anything done.
You're violating certain guidelines on
social media. That's some [ __ ]
What are things that made you better as
a programmer? If you want like my takes
on programming, okay, this is all free.
I'm not selling you anything on this.
This is just all of my best advice in
one place.
Here's general programming and general
programming and ML advice right here.
Will fail for your use case will give
you a headache. That is my expectation.
But the thing is, my use case is not
even something that I consider
particularly complicated. So like I
think it's mostly just devs using it for
easy [ __ ]
Joseph's LM bench once per year. Maybe
it's just that the LLM power users are
so incredibly obnoxious about
everything, you know? It puts me off of
it. And like I honestly let's say that
the models do get substantially better.
I don't even like the way in which they
are being implemented, right? Like the
idea of oh just write specs instead of
code just seems awful to me. Like I
would rather write code and then you
know have this thing watching me in the
background and like maybe autonomously
writing tests and compiling snippets and
like fixing bugs before I actually go to
compile. like I'd rather use it to allow
me to have more control over what I
write and like not have to think about
like niche technical bugs and stuff
rather than abstracting myself up
entirely to not thinking about the code.
You know, the way that these people are
like people are using these models is
just entirely anathema to me.
Co-pilot more than an agent. Well, it
can be an agent, right? Right? Like an
agent just means it runs a loop. Okay?
So like it can take snapshots of my code
and it can be running in the background
and writing tests and running like
that's cool, right? Or it could be like
going through docs looking up issues,
but I don't want it to like I don't want
to just do highle design and agent does
implementation, right?
Like the result of that is simply that
you will not have like you have no
influence over what you're doing and
like you just will very quickly have
zero value because you have zero
exposure to the actual thing you're
working with.
Curriculum trans curriculum transistors
web browser. No,
it's just asking developers to write
docs.
It's not quite that.
It sounds like more It sounds me to more
like people becoming more product
managers than um than devs. And I just
don't have very much respect for product
managers.
All right.
Let's start working on the real uh the
real currency here. Yeah, there's a
bitching about language malls all day.
It's instantly faster. Uh but now it
doesn't train.
This not doesn't train the same at
least.
Code security.
Memory safety.
Uh, honestly, memory safety is like,
well, okay, code security in that sense
is not really important. These are SIMs
where the thing you're deploying is not
the SIM. You're deploying the agent
ultimately. This is not like a public
facing service at all. Um, and memory
safety is just a massively overstated
class of bugs that is easily handled by
the compiler. Like we're easily caught
in debug mode by the compiler. You don't
need to massively change the language
for it.
Jira your product [laughter]
Google trans what I'm not going to just
like do random stuff while I'm in the
middle of
of trying to build something.
the goal for today is that we have um we
beat the solve time on breakout, right?
That's currently the goal.
So, I'm least confident in this kernel.
So, I can just do like
balls. And
actually, that's like that's doomed to
fail. Um
cuz I'll miss it if I don't have All
right,
that's the one colonel I really am not
happy with. All right. So, let's see.
Oh, I didn't compile. Hang on. Hang on.
How to learn it like using project-based
learning?
Well, I'm glad you asked. Here's a guide
that shows you exactly how to do that.
Make sure to feed the puff for a star on
GitHub. It's all great.
Two things that you should come
prepared. Use cloud code opia cloud code
only chat. Okay. Install MCP for web
search.
Okay.
Wait. What is Ging Gina AI paraly? What
is that?
Are these web search things?
What is this?
I mean, part of it is going to be I'll
start the stream early and we we will
configure some of this on stream.
Uh
system prompt you should use not using
anything apart from blood code. Okay.
So, not that complicated.
I didn't know that you needed third you
need third party stuff though for um is
that a thing you need third party
for just search.
Okay,
cool.
Okay, so that's pretty much the same.
Uh, that's not a full solve. It's quite
close.
So, uh, yeah, there's something screwy
with our fuse kernel. And I guess the
main thing is, is it this RMS norm?
Is it this RMS norm that's like super
slow?
Like if I comment this one norm out, how
fast do we get?
Because the thing is if I if I go
through cursor then people are going to
say that like oh you need to use like
this in the UI or that in the UI like
Oh, it's probably in the environment
right now, right?
Let's Okay. So, let's do this.
Uh, this is threads, right?
Eight.
Maybe ban on chat for the rest of the
day.
Permission to execute commands. Lovely.
So yeah, I'm going to definitely have a
fresh container for it then.
That is the one thing I will try to set
up before the stream is I will want to
give it a a fresh container.
Ah, right. Right. I forgot about this.
Okay. Um,
let me do this without without uh graphs
real quick.
There's this like graph issue we have to
fix with um environments.
Okay, graphs off. We're at 4.3 mil.
Uh, but are we not converging?
Let's not do custom kernels as well. I
want to make I just want it pure as
possible.
Yeah. So this is base speed with no
optimizations, right? It's 2.8.
Hey, Nico. Looking to develop an
environment for the theory of
everything. What scientific discovery
agents to solve curriculum current
scientific unknowns
engineering the theory like solving
places of a puzzle
any thoughts? Honestly, the way that I
see puffer being useful for scientific
discovery is by making um scientific
simulation substantially more powerful.
It's a lot less developing a theory and
more so giving you a way way way more
powerful uh tool to test hypotheses or
to like see if a specific outcome is
achievable under a certain set of
settings.
Okay, so threaded environment
definitely breaks.
No other changes,
which is very weird because I thought
that I checked that
I'm not looking to like adapt all this
stuff though, dude. I'm looking to do a
test, right?
Exactly what I'm looking for. Send your
message with the work. Cool. Thanks.
Hope it's useful.
Uh, what do we do?
So, apparently I broke threading
somehow.
I mean, we literally tested this thing
was correct, though.
device synchronize.
I missed that. I don't think so.
um
I haven't I'm a bit sketched that guy
cuz like
this is kind of an annoyingly
complicated setting. It's um
it's doing both GPU buffering and some
pretty fancy threading.
I'm actually not sure what to do about
this because I thought I tested this
like I had this piece of code tested
correct unless it's just the device
synchronization issue. And I can really
quick do a couple things like,
kind of the impression I'm getting.
Liberty, it's like there is tremendous
incentive to try to sell you the thing.
Hey K, happy new year. Your post is
doing quite well.
Welld deserved.
I'm really looking forward to using that
in as a um a major test environment in
40 as well. Yeah, I saw
um
Oh, it's now number one.
I guess this is yesterday,
huh?
Well, congrats on that.
I don't have an account on this thing,
dude. Do I? Dude, you need an account,
don't you?
Very nice. Yeah, that end is going to be
very, very useful.
As you can see, Kyouong, I've kind of
been fighting infrastructure hell for a
while.
No
performance.
Did you improve on um
Did you improve this
autonomous driving
policy. Well, you
don't just like deploy it with no extra
work, but yes, there are multiple
driving companies that are using the
thing.
Oh, well, now we have this as a perf
test.
So the main thing then is we're losing
all the PF on our ve because there's
some screwy thing wrong with this.
But
hang on. Buffers
one buffer
uh 8192 environments
red. This is the exact setting that we
have now, right?
And according to this, the buffers are
identical. See this?
what do we need to like send actions or
something?
Use GPU test index
size.
And according to this,
if you just receive and send back and
forth,
all the observations match.
So I
I'm trying to figure out how on earth
Okay. Um, I guess I should do action
test, right?
I'm trying to think what else it would
be.
I guess it could be that I send the
actions.
That is like very very odd right
here. Let me just real quick let me try
a couple things because just doesn't
make any sense to me.
Maybe we want accuded device sync before
back receive, you know. I don't know.
Send.
Maybe that's what we want.
very odd that there's like a
it would seem like a just a
some vectorzation work but
test passes.
This is on the deterministic version as
well.
hang on.
Yeah. So, this is the uh deterministic
version. So, let's just take this off.
And I just want to see if this messes
with anything just to rule out RNG
completely.
Yeah. Okay. So, this does not solve. So,
it's a straight up Beck bug.
I actually don't know how that's
possible.
Like, how do we just have a straight up
vectorization bug?
I tested this extensively.
Well,
let's go. Uh, let's make our test a
little better. I want to make sure then
that the uh it's not the send
That's the point, right? Trajectory
filtering should help.
It's not magic though. You know, if it's
a very small chunk of trajectories
that have the high data, it doesn't help
that much. That's actually something
that Puffer 5 is going to address.
Puffer 5 should help a lot for 2048,
actually, now that I'm thinking about
it.
Well, we can't have poker five until I
build puffer
is struggling at 32k.
I think said like there's I don't know
how consistent it is. Ask him.
Um,
that's awkward.
Is this the LM testing stream? Well, I'm
I said I would announce that the day
before.
I made a post with some details though.
This is currently we're trying to fix
well we have CUDA working. We have I
think most of the kernels working. Um
we're fixing now vectorization and we're
trying to get breakout to beat the um
the alltime speed test.
Actions.
Oh, wait. Cuz you copy GPU actions to
action. So, this is actually expected,
right?
So, I'd have to do like this then
because it's probably sending zeros.
oppos? Okay, that's interesting, right?
Because you have
if I put a device synchronize.
Ah, okay. Look at that.
Something's weird then because it's not
giving us the same
This is our first clue.
Yep. Okay. So, something is in the
action processing.
Do you know this? Yes. Is that that
dumb site
similar to hacker? No, it's not similar
to hacker news for AI only. It's similar
to hacker news but for idiots only.
Time to 12:55. Okay, let's see if we can
figure this one out. This is live. Yes.
Hello, snow.
Interesting. So, we set this back
actions.
So like I I cheated this copy because
it's synchronous anyways, right?
Yeah. So I cheated this copy. So
whatever, right? Action ready on GPU.
Oh well, no because I just made a race
condition, right?
Yeah. So then this is expected [ __ ]
So, the easiest thing would be if I
could just set um
All right, that is actually just
But I don't have Cuda in here, do I?
Okay. Okay. What if instead what if I do
this?
I'm just trying to figure out like a
good way to test this, right?
post fillet.
Yeah. So, we should just do
Okay. So, what we want to do is we want
to copy in data to
this one on host.
Yeah, copy same data to this. This will
work. I'm just trying to figure out a
consistent way to test um that my action
ve like the action side of the
vectorzation is not broken.
So we do this synchronize
start to end. We just do uh action
supplies action like this, right? And
then we just do like a cuda
Copy. Where is it?
It's going to be back one. GPU actions
going to be where is it?
Block size.
And I think that this is still not
linked correctly.
Boom. So, this one is wrong. Good.
And then this one is right.
So, um,
if I give it random action data, it's
still correct, right?
So weird.
Okay. What happens if I do this?
I'm looking at this test.
This seems like a very good test to me.
And somehow it trains when I have
threading off, but not when I have
threading on.
for the folks who got here relatively
recently. So to explain the problem um
this is like I don't know day five or
six worth of biting cudigraphs and uh
custom kernels and the torch li the lib
torch API and uh GPU buffered
multi-threaded vectorization and all the
things that are going into 40 and we
pretty much have it now where we can
train the end to end in C++ and it works
correctly and it'll solve breakout and
now we're kind of isolating all the
numerical errors when we turn on all the
speed features. And for whatever reason,
we have what should be a very good test
uh that our multi-threaded backend for
environments is correct.
But when I go to train it with
multi-threading on it does well, it
trains somewhat, but it doesn't converge
to the same score.
Like it the test just doesn't match.
So, let me use a restroom real quick.
I'm gonna actually take a few minutes
this time and I'm going to go get myself
a mug of tea
and
I mean, we have to assume that this is
some sort of weird synchronization issue
then or something, right? Because like
this test is passing.
So, perhaps we're calling it wrong or
something from the main
uh from the main script. I don't know.
I'll be back in a few. The goal is if we
can get this thing working today, we
should be able to set a new um training
speed record on Breakout, which will be
kind of like the first evidence of 40
being great. And
I think we can realistically get to like
six or seven mill steps per second
before we have to fix our mess norm. And
then maybe eight or nine when we take
the profiling out. And then there's
going to be a little bit more for the
release. But I'll be back.
We're going to do the other numeric
check
observation two mismatch.
So
We're going to basically see if we can
do this torch check that uh worked
before.
We're going to run this to see if the uh
if the obs buffer for the first epoch is
the same. And this should hopefully let
us find the issue.
I think that's probably the most uh the
best bet. It's like the other test that
is passing should be a very good test.
Okay. Okay. So this here, you know, you
see you get your check passed,
right?
activation one mismatch. Okay.
So,
yeah, according to this thing, we're
getting different ops.
According to this thing, we are getting
different
neither of these look good.
The heck
weird.
So
Well, the OP should not be zero
initially. Like what the heck is wrong
with this thing?
You know, why don't we just try to go
match this to the uh the other
implementation as well
do this right
back in for thief.
Okay.
Something screwy.
Yeah. There we go. Right. This is what
we expect.
This is how it should be. And this one
is empty for some stupid reason.
So if I set this to zero,
is this fixed now all of a sudden?
Yeah. You see that?
So you get zeros on your first op with
eight threads.
I mean that's like real data, right?
Oh, wait. Where's OBS?
OBS is scrap obs.
Oh, roll out copy fall.
Ops is nobs.
Okay. So we're going to copy into nob
from nobs rather.
Roll out copy call.
So graph ops gets copied in.
This is how this works. Yeah.
Graph ops gets copied in.
Supposed to
Uh so then the question I suppose is
like
after back reset
right. So, right. Yeah. Here. It's
supposed to already be set up.
Okay.
Uh, what the heck is this supposed to
be?
Well, this was not the intended outcome
at all.
But can we see the first one of this
zeros?
Yeah. So, your first two are all zeros,
it looks like.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
OBS ready
on CPU.
update buffer state to OBS being ready
on CPU
Well, it's not
Oh.
Yeah, this doesn't transfer correctly.
So, this is definitely wrong for reset,
right?
Yeah. So, this is definitely wrong on
reset
because it assumes that you've cued the
transfer.
What?
[laughter]
All right. Uh, yeah, I didn't need to do
that.
Okay,
now we have our thing back.
Uh, we still have OBS one mismatched.
Yeah, we still have ops one mismatch
somehow.
But at least now we're no longer just
looking at the first OB. So that's
progress.
obvious one mismatch.
That looks pretty close to me.
This is the same.
This one's the same.
And then this one's different, right?
Oh, but there's this dot dot dot.
So, this is different. This one's
different. This one's
interesting.
Okay. So, look, we have 495
that for the heck.
should actually match us perfectly for
the first
is that 495 is a weird index, right?
That's 256 should be 512.
Yeah. So, it's like almost all of them
that are messed up.
I do wonder if um
the thread RNG mess with other stuff.
It shouldn't. There's no RNG being
triggered on Cuda.
State is equal to actions already on
CPU.
How is this one off already on the
second OBS
when the other test
has it correct
as it is correct like the whole time
throughout?
That's what I don't understand.
This is supposed to register a block
completion
and then it transfers
ops rewards and terminals.
Yeah, we have computer graphs off.
There's way too many copies.
Uh, okay.
Let's figure out why that's happening.
update
buffer state so that
buffer state gets updated Yeah.
state.
Let me say so this is
state
gets update. There's only one of these
threads.
Update buffer state.
And this just gets this loads and stores
it. Right.
So
CUDA ready
actions ready on GPU
I just don't understand how this is
that.
Why does this seem like it's instantly
screwed on this and not on the other
one?
I spent a lot of time ensuring this
thing was correct.
I guess I can here. Hang on. Let me try
one thing.
No, it's
it's fine.
And look, there's one copy per as well.
You see that?
Oh, hang on.
Okay, it's fine that it prints a bunch
because
I forgot I'm running the loop.
So, this will pass. And if I set it to
two.
Okay, now this fails.
I get two copies,
which is as expected.
So we're not calling it the wrong number
of times weird. That's good.
Um,
I'd still think then this has to be some
sort of weird synchronization bug,
right?
Because otherwise like this test should
catch it.
But what
I mean there's not that much happening
here.
We have synchronized everywhere for
testing anyways.
the I mean the cuda level one task has
to catch all the torch streams, right?
Yeah, obviously
Um I do wonder.
Okay, we do have some additional stuff I
can test here. So
because I I want to make sure that
there's not like some small
RNG quirk.
Yeah. You see? So even if I use this
version,
Actually, I'm looking at this.
Wait.
Does that tell us something? Cuz
everything
Oh, not everything else is the same.
So this is the same
two.
Well, the X is different.
The ball X is actually different.
All fired.
Oh, wait. The fired is different.
It's like not even getting stepped then,
right?
the C++ one, right?
Wait, these are both calling the same
bloody code.
What did I do here? So this is
just make it consistent with
itself.
So this says the ball has been fired
and this says the in C++ it hasn't been
which makes no bloody sense.
Right.
This has not updated.
Okay,
I can confirm that observation is wrong.
But I guess in this case it's probably
some niche sync bug
01 right
buffers buffer on buffers
going to be super careful because I I'm
pretty sure I did this right, but I just
want to be absolutely positive.
It looks like somehow the end just isn't
stepping.
How long have you ever worked without
asleep?
I think there was one time in um I was
like 16 or something and I had
I think like a like a couple projects.
No, it was like one project and then
like yeah, one code project and then one
very large electronics project with a
very small code component. Uh you can
work on electronics for a very very long
time without rest because it's like
mostly a mechanical thing, right? You're
building stuff. I think I did something
like 65 out of 72 hours were just work
and I was already incredibly sleepd
deprived going into it. I was literally
seeing [ __ ] by the end.
Okay, a buffer zero. Well, I z buffer
zero. Good. So, this goes away.
And why is this not getting copied?
And why why are we not getting copies
here?
Um,
Yeah, I don't do that anymore. That only
works when the work that you're doing
doesn't require you to think.
What I'm doing now, this is kind of just
like staring at a very large wall that
has a very small crack and trying to
find the very small crack
in the very large wall.
How did you start with electronics? Now
was the course. I really don't do much
um much of anything other than
programming these days.
A little bit of administrative stuff for
my business.
Vast majority of my time is spent
programming.
insane practices of long work. Honestly,
not that much.
Like the grad students were nowhere near
as um it's really not the grad students
who are typically working the crazy long
hours, man. It's usually the undergrads.
I mean, I think I I think I was I worked
like through the full night um and into
the morning for each of the major neural
MMO releases, but in the scheme of
things, that really wasn't that bad.
Basic scripting experience in Python.
Well, it's definitely possible to learn
ML. I would just eliminate the with the
help of AI chunk of that at the end
there.
Check out my programming and ML guide on
my X articles tab.
You should probably just go through the
uh the CS231N coursework and start
building some stuff.
Okay, you know, let's let's debug a
couple things.
I seen that there was this crazy
freaking crash out where some dude
thought that he like solved everything
and was just a [ __ ]
Okay, so look, we get all this
and then I see all the starting steps,
right?
So, it's triggering these steps
and I see this copy
Okay. Know, so there is actually a
difference
including on the first one.
Um, but then
that's so weird. Cuz
like this is
Okay. Look, it's still not there. Cool.
Yeah. So it's not that fine.
This is definitely not stepping.
there. Riot does some RL like they have
some stuff published.
TFT has a really obnoxious observations
and action space for reference.
Never die is always sell.
I mean, I sure damn well hope so.
That's what I see myself as working
towards.
Um,
I don't think it's going to come out of
like we just make the LLM and then ask
the LLM to cure the disease, right?
But like, yeah, you can do pretty
freaking awesome stuff with tech.
Do you ever doubt if you're smart enough
or something or skilled enough? No. I
usually feel like just barely competent
enough to do the stuff that I want to
do. And then I look around and everybody
else is just running around on fire. So
I just say, "Well, no, if I can't figure
this out, nobody else is going to be
able to either. I'm in the best possible
position to be able to build this stuff.
So, gotta be me.
I mean, I stream all the stupid [ __ ]
that I do in the process of building,
you know, all these updates, but you see
that if you count by months, right? like
the next update comes out and RL gets a
lot faster
and there are some major breakthroughs
consistently with each version.
So,
a lot of what I'm doing really is not
magic.
Like right now, for instance, finding a
freaking stupid synchronization bug
keeps you moving.
Um, I mean, I'm like, this is going to
revolutionize
RL. It already has, but like it it can
be much more so.
So, it's pretty freaking awesome to be
able to sit here and flip a branch of
science upside down that's going to be
directly useful in a number of areas.
Bench and RL are [laughter]
Oh, I don't just bench and do RL. I also
run and deadlift.
the hell. Okay, let's let me just go
double check in here because and this is
getting ridiculous, right? Like we can't
just be here.
So,
so when you call receive, right?
receive doesn't do anything in the uh
the single thread case because it just
is all done on step for you.
Dark, we don't discuss politics of any
variety uh that are not directly related
to AI here. This is attack channel.
So this is just
I mean there is a huge difference in how
this is executed obviously but I don't
understand because we have a test for
this
like we have a test for this exact Okay.
like
I see
the copying op here, right?
Happy New Year.
Happy New Year to you as well.
I see the freaking copy operation
I mean I guess I can check
let's see 0 1 2 3 4 five Six.
Maybe this will tell us something,
right?
copying
observations of six is 2.
Okay. But then when we look here, it's
not.
I don't do New Year's resolutions are
dumb.
If you need to wait until New Year to
make a change, you're not going to make
the damn change.
I mean I can see the data being
completely uh correctly computed here
that would make the most sense right it
is the most likely that I'm just not
synchronizing
between torch and non. Okay, let me see.
So
we call back receive
actually this is another a good test. So
we'll just say
[clears throat]
currentations
of six equals
GPU observations six.
Miss a lot of not knowing the world. I'm
23. That would be why
better long-term if I learn tech and
math. Any recommendations?
Um, I mean there's my generic
programming guide, but it's more of a
like if you're already learning
programming or you have some experience.
This is how to save a bunch of time and
these are my best general
recommendations.
The guy the ex like the articles on my
tab uh my programming and ML guide, my
RL guide cover the uh the areas I work
in.
I don't do like a huge amount of general
educational material though.
The main thing around here is just um me
live streaming all of my research and uh
engineering.
Seg fault. Seg fault. Oh, okay.
Right. Because it's a GPU buffer, dummy.
Um, okay.
Okay. Yeah. So, I just do um float
six. [snorts]
Okay. Uh,
well, this is weird.
Return from back receive
zero.
Return from receive.
So, this is copying.
Now, this is returned.
So it does look like this is wrong
somehow.
You have an async copy queued up here
back streams of buffer,
It didn't have that high of a
publication count
in PhD.
Yeah. Look at the topic that I was
working on.
I ran a couple of the largest
competitions and um
a couple of the largest competitions at
NerS
and I had a ton of engineering work on
neural MMO.
In fact, it's kind of funny like the
thing that ultimately was required
uh was even more engineering. So like I
was able to do a ton of it during my
PhD, but the thing that actually enabled
Puffer to take off was just way way more
engineering than even that.
You know, sort of the theory that we
were really bottlenecked by tools and
infrastructure can only be tested so
much there.
I don't I don't
the hell type of question is that dude.
This buffer can't be spinning for any
other op can it
streams of buffer.
Is there anything else that this could
be using the stream
because also right we load
we block until obs are ready on CPU
right
yeah this is designed correctly like
prolific prof well
let me see forers lab is doing some
pretty good stuff like consistently for
a while I disagree with some of the
engineering on it but he's consistently
cranking work
um the lab I work with at the moment uh
collab with is Eugene
I think they've got probably one of the
better blends of engineering and
research. Um, they're mostly on the
driving environment at the moment, but
it's like still a quite good problem and
it blends uh together number of
different things. And other than that,
like obviously there's some stuff at
Berkeley, but it's going to be mostly
robotics type stuff, which is really
outside of my direct area. I do like um
I do low dimensional control with some
of the stuff with puffer, but we're
really not in the space of um like high
dim control at the moment.
There were there are like a few other
people. The thing is it's not even labs,
right? Most of the works that I knew
that were super awesome uh during my PhD
were random individual students at
random labs, right?
like Costa was at Drexel. Um
I think Oxford. No,
Queens. I don't know where Bamford was
when he did Gridly. That was pretty
nice. Um there a few other projects like
that that were just from random students
at random places that were very good.
There really haven't been a bunch of
just RL labs
uh for several years at this point.
Like I was really the only one doing a
ton of core RL uh in Philips lab at MIT
as well.
Yeah. So, I don't understand how this
could possibly screw up, but just to be
sure, this is what I'm going to do. What
happens if I do this, right? Oops. If I
just make this a CUDA me copy uh
synchronous
Okay, this is still zero. So I don't
understand. You get this copy,
right?
OBS ready
on CPU. Oh, wait. Is this in the wrong
order?
Hang on.
If I put this down here,
I swear if I messed this up, I'm going
to be quite irritated.
Uh, I think I actually just genuinely
messed that up.
But then I have no idea how this
wouldn't have gotten caught in the
testing.
That's super bizarre.
Yeah,
that now passes.
That's so bizarre. How did this not get
caught?
I had like a pretty solid test I thought
that I put together.
At least I found it,
you know. At least I found it.
I 50. What is this? I something or
other.
That's pretty embarrassing to have a
genuine VE bug, but
I guess as far as bugs in that go, I've
spent way longer fixing them. It's okay.
Oh, yeah. How's Kung's hacker news thing
going?
Well, it's gotten a lot of attention,
but I don't know what this thing is.
4713.
Do remember to feed the stuff the
puffer. Isn't 2048 trivial with RL to
get 2048? Yes. But um
he got it to 65,000 score.
So
Nice. All right, it works now.
Um,
and
do we get anything?
Okay, I think it matches.
Yeah, I think it matches. 750 is what I
saw before. Okay,
let's double check.
Just want to run this a few times and
make sure I'm comfortable with this.
And we'll commit this
and continue.
Oh yeah, I forgot we determinized.
That's probably going to mess it up.
Yep. Forgot about that.
Oh, and it's still 7:47, so we're good.
Yeah, we forgot to determine it. Okay,
great. Shrimp fell back.
Um,
I think we are a okay now.
We still have to try multiple buffers.
We got to try lots and lots of other
stuff, but we're getting there cuz it's
progress.
and get myself another cup of tea if
this works. So, we do the commit. Take a
couple minutes. And then I got at least
another couple hours before I got to go
to New Year's festivities.
I might even do evening stream. We'll
see.
Okay. Native
C multi-threading
is fixed
at least for one buffer so far.
Okay, cool. I'm going to use the
restroom real quick. I'm going to get
myself another mug of tea. And uh then
what we're going to do is
oops
maybe we'll see if we can get the VEC to
work with photographs next. I don't
know. There's still like several more
issues we got to work through to have
the end to end working. But we'll just
ceue up the next one. Give me a few
minutes.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> So hungry.
Let's go with this.
Uh, I eat out, but I eat like well a mix
of reasonably healthy things and then
less healthy things by requirement
because I don't have the appetite to eat
the number of calories that I need.
I'm in Florida at the moment. Florida
has a lot of diners. I like diners.
Okay. Operation not permitted when it
stream is capturing function reset. So
you track calories. So normally calories
is always I it's just always too low. Um
like I haven't eaten anything today.
I've had a protein shake today. That's
all I've done.
Um so it depends on the things. It
depends on the routine I'm on. I have
some fitness stuff here. This was the
latest like thing from the summer.
Uh I have where's the 50k article?
Yeah, this was the endurance running
block
and I have a few other miscellaneous
things around as well. It kind of just
depends on uh what the current goals are
though.
At the moment, I'm balancing between
trying to get a lot of work done, which
means not having time to be eating tons
of meals, but then I also have this
really nice um uh this really nice
serious bodybuilding gym nearby. So, I'm
trying to put some muscle back on. Um
yeah, and I'm kind of just like every
other day going there for at least two
hours
and uh having some full days for work.
I will say the one thing that I have
that you'll see me have on stream often
and it's in this mug usually. Um this is
just tea, but I'll make like um a
protein hot chocolate with 66 g of
protein.
That usually help balance out any other
inadequacies.
The summer cut was literally 1500
calories per day while uh running like
40 some odd miles a week.
the reason that this needed to be
graphed was what?
Like
this is the roll out copy one, right?
Roll out copy graphs.
Roll out
ops buffer.
Yes. The reason here is wait ops
This doesn't get used.
Do we introduce a couple more buffers?
What do we do?
I like all these temp buffers. Anyways,
what if we do it this way?
Can everything else be stable?
If I just do um
That's almost on par with current max
speed already.
Okay, so that's on par with soda. I
think that's actually faster. That's
That's a 25 second solve for breakout,
folks.
It depends how what margin you give
yourself, but I'd say that's a
pretty solid.
Now, next thing.
If I set this to two, does everything
break?
Yes. Yes, it does
apparently.
Okay.
So, both is to false.
If I set number two, does it break?
Okay, this is the number I perform. So
at least this was expected to crack
>> [laughter]
>> That's fine.
Okay. So, this is double buffered.
slower.
Oh, we have a whole bunch of
synchronizes. So, this Don't worry about
this.
you wake up. Ideally, yes.
I've got family here at the moment, so
it's a little bit um uncertain,
but yeah, usually in my uh I have at
least a few work blocks a year, like
several weeks where I have a very
regimented schedule. I have like some
specific fitness routine as well
associated or goal and um you know, some
well-defined research objective.
At the moment, it's a little bit more
variable. I'm trying something where I
have a few days of the week where I just
focus on research and a few days of the
week where I uh do a few hours of work,
spend a lot of time in the gym, do a few
more hours of work after.
Okay, so this runs perfect. We're good.
Um, that means our buffered environments
actually work, which is pretty great.
Now
we go back to our kernel version
and kernels
and this on.
Very nice. That's actually faster than
before even with the syncs. 5.8 million
steps per second.
So way less efficient. Uh, I mean it
depends. Like
I need to get my exercise at some point.
So if I go in the morning, you know,
then I miss out on like I sort of start
my day already being tired. It's also
like if I just have the same routine
every day as well, it does it does get
monotonous.
So, um it's kind of interesting to me to
like to try this out and see if this
lets me be more focused on the focus
days and then sort of get some amount of
recovery in on the other days.
I mean, ultimately, as long as I feel
like I'm making good progress on this
release, I'm going to be happy. So,
and so far release progress is being
made.
It's a little different I think in this
case as well because this is like I'd
say that this work block is particularly
just soul brushing. Um the work I'm
doing now is just very fiddly. It's very
slow. A lot of stuff is completely
undocumented. Like
you know this is not the usual
I'd say this is like substantially
harder uh to remain focused on than the
usual research work.
I'm actually curious what are we losing
from the norm right now.
I just want to see how bad this thing
is. 5.8.
6.5. Yeah. So, you do you get a pretty
big bite taken out of Perf with this RMS
norm,
We'll try that other dynamic tan age
thing
at some point soon.
Uh, I'm also I guess now we want to
start on
probably want to get some of these
synchronizes out.
So, let's add
we have this bool for cudigraphs
Now, we're going to put all these
synchronizes behind um
behind some flags.
And we didn't end up using these good
events. So, we get rid of these.
We can just do if
up from profile like this
profile
that
this and that one. That one at the
bottom. You actually need that
synchronized for now.
Is that it? That's it.
So
now we have
hopefully that should kill a bunch of
overhead.
I think I left a little bit of it in the
vectorzation. Maybe
I should also add ve receive to the
profile list for sure.
Six mil
very small speed up.
I'm interested to make sure.
Okay, so the good thing here was that
those synchronizes don't break anything.
That's the nice key. And we still have a
few things that are missing.
Um, so let's just let's just commit this
to six mill stable real quick.
Oh, that's totally soda, by the way. 23
seconds.
I think that realistically
uh I think it is actually going to be
possible to hit 10 second breakout
training
in this update. It will be very tight,
but if we can hit 10 second breakout
solve, that would be amazing,
you know? I think that would just be so
cool
to solve Breakout in 10 seconds on one
GPU.
So not
that's funny.
Okay.
Next bits. Um
we have to do
So if I do the fuse PO loss,
if I do this one, does it break?
I think I probably do have some minor
bugs in that kernel.
We'll see.
It also doesn't seem to help.
Very small increase.
Yeah, but like look at this, right?
It's still training, but uh There's
definitely some numeric wrong with this
kernel.
The other kernels seem fine.
Okay, so we know that this one's worked.
What about the roll out uh the roll out
graph thing?
Okay. So, what if I do? Let's just see
if I can throw a device synchronize in
here and have it work
because I would like to not have to mess
this house flawed. going uh we're not
doing that stream yet, Luke. We're doing
the by hand make
RL soda speed.
That's the current objective.
We got it to 6 million steps per second
stable, which is pretty cool.
And then we have the optimizations up to
9 mil. But there's some numerical bugs.
And then there's one activation function
needs to get replaced
or one function rather.
you know, just wait for
all the streams.
stream operation not permitted when
stream is capturing function reset.
What's a good approach in C for error
messaging?
This is not C. Error messages in C are
actually totally fine as long as you're
debugging your code with address
sanitizer. Um, this is C++ and mostly
cuda just being evil.
I did eventually want to have like the
threaded reset because it would be a
little faster.
Um,
but this is a pain in the ass. So,
I'm do this for now.
Okay. Operation failed due to a previous
error in capture.
Uh well, this is it can't be this.
The easiest thing would just be to
separate them for now.
Like everything is freaking async,
right?
You create all these strings.
What do you actually do though? Because
like ve reset you can totally just make
sync, right?
Like is this thing supposed to be in
queuing any ops?
Yeah. Okay. I think it is easiest to
just not start these things.
Like if I just do
I mean if we literally just do like this
right and void create threads
back
and just do this
Would you change your opinion?
Well, yeah, I would change my opinion,
but in what I mean, I'm probably going
to change my opinion in some direction,
you'd imagine.
I think the most likely thing, let's say
the models dramatically surprise me and
are amazing.
I still doubt that the conclusion of
that is going to be, oh, I should just
vibe code everything. I think it would
probably be like, okay, these tools are
good. I really hate the way that people
are using them. Let me come up with uh
let me come up with a way that doesn't
just offload all of your uh all of your
decision- making and cognition to the
LLM and figure something better out.
But I still think it's very unlikely
that we even get that right. I think
that basically the models are just going
to be really stupid
and it's going to be more frustrating
than it's worth
and then you know possibly down the line
I think is what's probably going to
happen is that I mean if we're just
tracking the way that I normally work
right as the models get better
eventually I'll adopt them in some form
but it'll be like a much lighter weight
and less intrusive form than everyone
else typically uses kind of like The way
I do have I do have a model. You see me
use a model all day, right? Like look at
this thing. But it's a really fast
stupid model. It doesn't get in my way
and it doesn't try to think for me.
Look, Liberty, I am occasionally
completely wrong about stuff. Just
doesn't happen that often. No.
This is nice.
What is this?
Oh, it's like a little
That's funny.
Oh, Ray Lip is on here.
Rail is great software.
Lot of little games.
threads.
What the heck did I do here?
Uh, create threads
Okay. So, you don't need threads here.
Need buffers.
Uh, you do need buffers. Apparently,
block size.
Yeah. Okay.
Threads.
Block size.
We don't need to get it back
Block size. We don't need to get it back here.
Great environments.
And then this is the totally wrong
place.
Oh, that's a little awkward, isn't it?
Well, I guess I can do it like this,
right?
And then num threads is going to be
eight
six like this I guess.
Take threads out. Buffer stays.
Lock size goes.
Okay, that now works. Lovely.
Um,
like your idea for a better approach
converted class from
agent test everything in debug.
Yeah, I mean I would think that like
That seems substantially better to me,
right?
Offloading logic is kind of just an
aathema to me.
Now, offloading like, you know, testing
and diagnosis and testing of really
niche [ __ ] with whatever library or
whatever you're currently working with.
Um,
that would seem way better to me.
Like if I could just write all the code
and the code never has bugs, that would
be cool. And obviously like you know
bugs can be a result of design flaws or
they can just be a result of like misuse
or minor omission. Like obviously if
there's a design flaw, it would just
have to tell you, hey, like this doesn't
work because whatever. Um,
in the same way like an LSP will tell
you if you missed a semicolon, right? If
you could take that up higher and have
it doing stuff at the like at the level
of compiling your project and writing
like little unit tests on lines of code
as you're writing it, that would be
pretty cool. Um,
you actually don't want to keep those
unit tests around, of course, but
But the models are not good enough to
even do this yet.
That was not our term. Yeah, exactly.
like they stole our worked and then
their agents are ass. So
Yeah, this takes a back end
and sides.
This can go here. Um, but what is wrong
with this
undefined symbol?
function
need to be exported.
MCP.
Yeah. I mean, you get stupid terms
because there are now a lot of stupid
people in the field. B and behold.
We just uh we just infinite loop, huh?
That what we do.
Mhm.
Very cool.
Still no. Huh? Still no.
Interesting.
All right, let me address the rest real
quick and then we continue. I'm making
progress today. So, this is a good
progress.
It finally feels like this is starting
to come together though,
which is very nice.
We know we have at least one bad kernel,
but
you know, it's still it's very close
now. It's very close. All
right, let's see what the heck this
infinite loop is.
Okay, threads are created.
This actually returns
Okay. So,
we hanging here.
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing.
Um,
I mean, so this doesn't have any
threading in it.
This should be fine.
And we actually get to call the create
threads
method.
Oh, but you know what? We didn't test if
um
we didn't test if you actually needed
this
set, right?
Well, why not?
Why not just do this?
I mean, it's not like super nice or
anything super brittle.
We can get something that lets us test
the end to end though and actually get a
breakup solve in a good time
and get under 20 seconds today. Maybe
Right. And we're slow now because we
don't have the optimizations on.
Uh so let's put these [clears throat]
back on with photographs.
So now that lets us graph that chunk of
code
It's a very small improvement, but it's
an improvement
and uh we can start making larger
improvements from here.
So this gets us what? A couple hundred
thousand steps per second. Not a huge
improvement, but a small improvement.
there's like this norm function that's
really obnoxious.
It's just an RMS norm. Um
I'll show you why it's obnoxious here.
So it's just a norm, right? It should
take no time.
Look at that. Million steps per second
taken up by this norm. Actually more.
That's 1.4 million steps per second.
That's ridiculous.
And up to 7.6.
So, um,
let me go find this norm that, uh,
somebody posted one that looked okay.
Yeah. So it's this thing
learnable scaler.
Is it a single scaler?
This is not remotely what they just
described,
right?
Oh, this is a skeleton shift. Okay,
fine.
Um, yeah, let's see if we can implement
it real quick.
I stupid like windowing thing. Okay,
we'll do this
I think this one was the bad one, right?
Yeah, here it is.
Nothing. Nothing is an easy formulation
with the torch C++ API being what it is.
Look at this [ __ ]
Alpha gets
on
this.
Wait,
Okay,
wait.
Okay. And now all we need to do is
There's this register parameter thing.
Oh, wait. These are already registered.
Cool.
No, I didn't figure out channels. This
is their own implementation. This is
that's a different thing, man.
Better than layer norm. I tried RMS
norm. I don't know if I tried layer
norm.
I will tell you. Well, actually
layerorm I think is
isn't RMS norm less obnoxious because
it's per
I actually know batch norm is the
obnoxious one. I forget whether layer
norm is also obnoxious.
I don't like any of them anyway. They're
all freaking slow. Anyways, man, if we
can just get something that's not slow,
I'll be happy.
most models use. Yeah. And they're slow.
They're so slow.
Not rely on. Okay. Yeah. So, batchorm is
the obnoxious one. They're only
obnoxious in the sense they're stupidly
slow operations and uh they seem so
simple, but then you go try to compute
the backwards pass and uh jump out the
nearest window
cuz you get absolutely god awful cross
terms.
right. RS norm is eating 1.4 to 1.6
million steps per second of performance
right now for reference.
So RMS norm is taking
like
it's taking a pretty decent chunk of the
total time of training.
Um,
dang. I did this right, didn't I?
Oh, we I didn't even look at the SPS.
Well, it worked better than not having
anything.
Look at that. 7.6. So, it's still slow
somehow.
I implement it right? I would think so.
interesting. One tan doesn't actually
really cost anything.
So, what the heck is that? Like, what is
costing stuff that
weird?
Oh, that's actually super funny though.
The one tan age does as much as their
thing does.
X derivative
parameters
could Okay.
It still didn't work as well though.
Like it didn't solve
Well, you lose. It doesn't solve the
thing, it seems.
At least without returning hypers.
I'm confused as to why. Hang on.
What's the output of this thing? So,
this is supposed to be
you take your gate.
This is a lurp between the state
and the hidden.
Let's just make sure it's not
a couple things we can fiddle with here
real quick.
So, if I just stick a yellow on this,
what bit depth are using? Yeah, this is
below 32.
There is some stuff we can play around
with with Bflat. Um,
but initial tests were not numerically
stable. Okay, so you cannot just stick a
yellow on it. Dang.
Don't need this one.
Hey, this is super annoying because like
look at the difference.
Is this not supposed to be? Hang on. Is
this not learnable?
This parameter.
Where's their um
these are all normal.
Yeah, these are all learnable.
I can try a couple quick things with
diet.
Um,
but then I'm going to like stop on this
for now and we'll just go back to perf.
I really hope we don't have to have
these RMS norm layers in here though
because they're like just unbelievably
slow.
I mean presumably
well I guess it depends.
We now do have this sort of block
structure to our nets.
There's actually quite a bit of new
architecture work that could be done.
Um, now that we have our nets this way.
Um, I don't know why, but this is not
fast.
No, it's not the trig function. I tried
the tanh to see if it was the tanage and
the tanage is fast. So, actually,
there's no point in this cuz it's also
slow.
So, we'll keep this norm for now.
We'll keep this norm for now and we'll
go from here.
It's all right. That one actually looked
that was actually a reasonable thing to
propose, man. Like for once, this was
something that's like super easy to
test. Looked pretty reasonable. I mean,
there might even be something to it and
it might even be easier. Like you could
write something uh you could write a
kernel for this really easily by
comparison, right? I would think
or fuse it into another kernel really
easily.
Oh, I guess. Hang on. Alpha times
Well, they have this like rescale thing.
What happens if I just do
So this is this would actually be the
scaled version, right?
Well, there's a norm in here still. Hang
on,
dummy.
So, that'll be fast. Um,
I'm also kind of wondering if people
have played with Whoops.
Like do you throw the norm on just the
output or you know the sum or like the
input All right.
look at that.
That's interesting.
I wonder if that's actually more
reasonable if this is just like a less
aggressive norm.
It's a little worse though. That's not a
full solve.
I'm just I'm just playing with this real
quick.
There's definitely something to it
though. Like it's definitely better than
not having a dorm.
And um
yeah.
Well, I don't know. there is or not.
Like we can always run some hyper sweeps
and stuff.
Yeah. See, this is not as good. All
right. So, I mean, there's like there's
some bit of promise, but
leave this for now. This disappointing
though cuz we're losing a whole bunch of
our speed here.
Let me make sure this is stable. Then
we'll go add a couple of our other
optimizations back in and see what
matters.
And the problem is I don't want to play
too much with architectures here because
this is just breakout, right? So like
architecture changes that work on
breakout not exactly the best guarantee
that it works everywhere. It's like
enough to be interesting and that's
about it.
Okay, we'll try B float uh in the
optimizer for Newton Scholes real quick.
Yeah, it's a very small improvement, but
it's free, it seems.
So, that's fine.
Leave that there.
YouTube's eating messages. It does that
sometimes. Depends what you're typing.
Uh I mean, we can save a couple nulls
here.
How many people currently work? Well,
it's all done through contracting.
Um Spencer is by far doing the most
amount professionally though with us.
I don't have anyone else. Do I have No,
I don't have anyone else on active
contracts right now.
Well, I guess there is kind of one guy
that I placed with a client. Eh, there
are a few things.
Oh yeah, that is a little faster as
well.
Yeah, plus a very small amount.
I actually don't know what this is and I
don't know if that's CUDA graphite
update
I think we can do some more profiling
then.
We can do like ve send ve receive I
suppose
on profile.
We'll add ve to profile and we'll run a
new set of profiles now that we have um
we have it stable.
It's annoying because we should be up to
like what this should be close to 8 mil
now. Right.
Let me just real quick. If I go like RMS
norm,
I'm pretty sure this should be close to
8 mil.
7. Yeah, see close to eight. Hang on,
folks. I'll I'll be back. Give me a
minute or two.
What makes a good environment? Um, I
mean there are a lot of things you can
do, right? On the simpler side, you can
create environments that like challenge
the algorithm in a way that we haven't
done before explicitly or like tend to
have divergent results with different
algorithms, things like that. Um,
complex Ms are always good. So just like
very tough environments where there's a
lot going on and where you get this you
get like a log linear learning curve
over a ton of steps are nice. Um
proms are good as well.
It's having good trans like one other
thing is that just like if something
does well on this environment is it
likely to do well on other environments
which you can't really tell until you've
run a bunch of experiments. But this is
why I use breakout. It's the this simple
environment for which if stuff works
here there's a decent chance that it's
useful elsewhere like pong doesn't have
that property for instance pong is too
simple
let's go check if used PO kernel.
I want to see if this actually if we fix
this, will this actually give us a speed
up?
Very marginal speed up. Yeah, very
marginal.
It's honestly not worth doing.
That's not going to save us.
Think
we should probably have a profile on the
M speed,
right?
Oh. Oh, hang on. I didn't see this one
here.
Yeah, this is a big one.
synchronize
one synchronize.
That might actually do something.
How do you the RL models respond to
states in text yet it doesn't. That's
the thing. You don't use them on text.
You don't use them on stuff that's
designed for people.
They're superhuman for intuitive
optimization problems.
How does that not get us to speed up?
I should have deleted like
so normal speed you actually take like a
noticeable hit to per with profiling but
not huge less than 10%
animal or child? No.
Um,
no. Both of those have way more baked in
than RL. RL is way more from scratch
than either of those.
The good news is we can build fast sims.
So, we don't care if it needs a
bajillion samples because we have
unlimited samples.
There are a few things that we need to
into the algorithm still.
But for the most part, the most
effective thing has just been like raw
speed.
They do sort of build intuition. Yeah.
In a way,
like they can discover some stuff that's
pretty surprising as well.
Oh yeah, for whatever reason um
where is it? This thing did not get
enough attention. So if you have not
seen the drive result,
pretty major collaboration effort has
been finished.
I mean, you can take a look at this
compared to what was previously in the
drive in a lot of progress.
Cuda,
we may look at this real quick, right?
So
40% element wise chronals
seconds in element wise kernel. So this
is tiny right?
Yeah it's 0.1.
So this is tiny.
We don't need to care about these.
Oh, and here it is. Look,
now we actually have this is the tag we
care about. So
Yes, 5.4. So train board graph
56% time 5.4 seconds.
nonpersonal data center. No, I'm in
Florida for now. Uh, roll up graph.
Okay, so this is here
80ish%.
A little more. We're still leaking 15
20%.
Uh, roll out copy outputs is leaking a
half second.
Train misk is leaking
3 seconds.
I actually I'm quite proud of this spec
and invest.
We're leaking less than 5% performance
on the environments.15
seconds.18 seconds is tiny. I think we
can reclaim a little of this as well
because I have some stuff that should be
asing.
Um
I mean so this mostly means though that
The perf improvements need to come from
Ford or rollouts which is like actually
the core network.
Yeah. And you see their rollouts. They
went from 130 to 190 microsconds
This does not give us a good way to hit
10 mil though.
Take a look at our nets real quick.
I'm trying to think if otherwise the
only option we'll have left is the blow
to get faster.
Yeah, that's a 20 second breakout solve.
So that's new soda,
but um
transformer is ever worth it can be. Um
they're very obnoxious in RL though
because
like you get variable context window
I don't think that this is how it
actually works.
I think they cast the weights
It's in the capture. Okay. So yeah, this
is messed up.
Now I'm going to New Year's uh Eve
festivities and quite soon actually. But
I have been live for almost six hours so
far today.
No.
What I do wrong?
So,
uh, I see
the idea is this is the main mountain in
here. So,
okay,
that does do a thing.
Hang on.
I mean, that's got to be bait, right?
That's either a bait that's either bait
or somebody who has no business touching
a computer.
Yeah, that's not any faster is the funny
thing.
Oh, it is stable though. That's
interesting, right?
Look at that. Do the mat in um
doing the mat in B flip 16 is stable
though.
We actually have several ops we could
move to B&B flow 16.
It's actually I'm surprised that it's
not faster, right?
There profile on.
No, I don't. That should be full speed.
And that's actually slower than FP32.
Oops.
No, apparently not.
I screw up. Oh, that's just memory.
is the transformer being used for
synthetic data. What does that mean?
Yeah, exactly. N is
the only reason I'm even bothering to do
a stream sometime in the next couple of
days is going to be um is because like
Carpathy and a couple other folks have
been ranting about the new ones,
but I doubt it. Honestly, I still doubt
it.
Yeah, I mean, look at that. It's just
genuinely faster than FP 32.
That seems deeply wrong to me.
updates in the way that we would want
though.
I wonder if this actually makes the
difference?
Yeah, exactly. Anish, that's kind of
what I figure.
Okay, now this is weird. It's actually
not even faster than float 16.
I got to get the festivities soon. Let
me make sure I get at least a stable
version of this though.
Yeah, I I honestly don't know what the
heck, man.
I mean, the only other thing we can do
is probably just go get like um
a level profile.
There we go.
Does this have
Hang on. Is this actually going to be a
correct sub?
I don't see cutless kernels in here.
Um,
yeah. See this is not a correct
Oh, I think it's just with um cudigraph
one you get. Yeah, you don't want to do
it with cudograph one, I suppose.
want to take another look now at this.
Um, we can leave
kernels on. We're going to sets off
and I'm going to leave profile off so
that we don't iner extra syncs.
And then that'll hopefully give us extra
info. And now we've got 6 mil plus steps
per second stable training today.
in GPU.
Uh if it's like leak code then no. If
it's like puzzles,
if it's actually like implementing a
bunch of standard reasonable kernels,
then sure.
Okay,
there we go.
So
supposed to be a 10second profile.
Yeah, this don't worry about this. This
is fine. This is the one that matters.
So 10 second profile.
Uh we have
600 mm ms on this kernel.
This is that concatenate up
kernel.
So 512 by one
actually don't know what that one would
be.
Oh no, that's probably that loss.
The biggest one is this elementwise
thing.
I actually don't even know what this
would be.
These these don't add to 100 at all.
Right.
No, these don't add to 100.
They're like 5 seconds.
honestly these profiles it's probably
more useful to just like remove
operations and see what the time diffs
are.
It's very difficult to track like this.
I like the tagged regions though.
Let me just go double check what time um
festivities are planned. Um my family's
here. Be right back.
I know where everybody is, but I'm
assuming I have a few minutes at least
So like the easiest way to figure out
how much time we're actually spending in
our linear layers, right?
Please use Opus
for this stream. Sure.
That's pretty much what I've been
recommended anyways.
So you get plus 2 million SPS without
the core operation. Obviously it can't
like train anything.
But that's kind of funny that like
relatively small amount of time is being
spent in the actual computations,
right?
not seeing it to be useful at all? I
doubt I don't think so. We're going to
see you on the stream, though. This
stream is not today, man. Today, I'm
doing um
numerical fixes and optimizations to
Puffer 4.
We got a new state of the art for
breakout training. We solve in 20
seconds now.
So, we're not actually spending that
much time in these mountains. It's
pretty funny.
It tells us this is a lot.
Top two are element wise kernels.
Okay.
You do anything with that.
I think the fuse scan we actually have a
good profile. But um if I just did
like out equals output here? Can I just
do that?
See?
Yeah. What if I just do this? Out equals
output.
What if I just do this? Obviously, it
doesn't train, right? We don't care if
it doesn't train as long as we get perks
numbers.
not that much is being spent in the
mountains.
7.4.
Okay. So, this is actually like 2 mil
SPS here
almost as much as in the mats
for what should be a relatively simpler
operation.
I say this law values
state.
No, I consume plenty of stupid content,
just not in TV form.
other than a small a few small copies
here and there. This is like max
optimized. I think I mean the main thing
is going to be the kernels.
I was kind of just looking like
I think technically these ops here,
right?
And the other the only other good one is
the norm, right?
I hate this like this art thing that
just doesn't
in the paper.
Just flip the darn like just flip the
colors on the paper. That would be way
better.
It's actually funny because they
I don't think that they have the block.
They don't have the skip connect at all,
do they?
What the heck is their thing supposed to
be?
Did they just stack it?
finish. Um,
I train AI that plays games.
It trains really fast. A lot of problems
look like games.
that's the RMS norm paper just I was
just noting that they didn't even have
the RMS norm that's the mini group paper
they didn't have the RMS norm in the
paper it's just what I was noticing
Um,
guys,
I have no idea if this works with
anything harder.
Um, but that's a 16-second breakout.
This needs more work to determine to
what extent we need to like look at
this.
But this is 8.3 million steps per
second.
See, but like look, now it's
inconsistent,
right? Now it's inconsistent without the
norm,
whereas before was consistent.
Yeah. See
here, there it is again.
15 16 second breakouts
your color scheme. My color scheme is
inspired by puffer.
Let me just comment and crap.
Don't need this.
on. Let me go double check. It might be
time for festivities.
Okay, so festivities are soon. Um, rock
paper scissors. Uh, be sure that you
actually have them. Be sure they
actually exist, Jess.
And I would assume that
um, fictitious selfplay is enough until
proven otherwise. I wouldn't get nerd
sniped by the Alpha Star stuff until
you're positive that it exists.
Okay, so that's about the same. But like
look at this, right? It's unstable
without the norms.
Can I just like throw about one normal
at the start?
Let's just I want to have a little bit
of fun real quick with this. If I make
this one layer, what happens?
Remember, this is a four layer network
we're running.
What happens if I do
six this
Yeah, Kim, this is There's we're having
a problem with um the norms.
Like it's way more stable with norms,
but the norms are very slow.
Interesting. So
we can get a It's kind of nice that we
can get a very small method pass with
this. natively.
How many params? It's param matched with
the original LSTM. I haven't I haven't
added the like I have to export that
information from C++ man.
Now the thing is that this can solve and
this can solve in 16 seconds but it's
way more fiddly.
Whereas if I go back to this right and I
if I just add this back in
I'm done with the norm
If I just uncomment this, it'll be
consistent.
So, there's something we don't
understand about the stability of these
nets yet.
that 20 seconds with the norm, 16
seconds without.
Admittedly, actually 16 seconds is
pretty close to solved.
So,
20 seconds.
That means this is public. So, you all
can actually play with this if you'd
like.
There aren't really um instructions yet,
but
there are a few people in the Discord
that want to set it up.
I think realistically.
So, I want 10 mil before we launch. And
I think I can get it. Um I think we can
actually get the 10-second solve though
because we haven't touched hypers yet.
It should be able to hit 3132. I would
think so. I don't know if this network
is any better. Um it is faster and it
I've been able to match park with LSTMs
without having to retune Hyper. So I
would assume that there's some more that
can be gotten out of it with retuning
hypers but I don't know. Um
it's quite difficult to optimize though
like very little of the compute is
actually in the molds right now which is
not great.
Like if you just remove the main map
holes, you only get plus 2 million steps
per second.
I mean, to be fair, there are a bunch of
ways I can technically make this faster.
Fun morning. Yeah, I mean, good job on
the blog. Very, very good job. I'm
looking forward to using that. I'm just
not quite ready yet.
We've been kind of just grinding this
cuda stuff for many days at this point.
20 seconds though is still soda. So,
we got soda this year. Um,
it's a pretty nice perk improvement.
Yeah. There we go.
I mean the nice thing is this has way
more visibility at least than we had
before.
And we actually properly have the
majority of the time in training now.
Like the eval loop is quite tight.
I can probably do all sorts of
ridiculous things now. Um
hang on.
I can probably do
like some pretty ridiculous things
like let's say we're to do
Yeah. So, see that? Oh, that's actually
that's faster. That's nuts.
10.
So only 1024 m.
Yeah. So before that would have been way
slower.
Seems that that's actually faster now,
which is funny.
So there's going to be some pretty
interesting things that come out of
this. Um but I think that's it for me,
folks, for the year. So, um,
thank you for, uh, following all this in
2025.
I don't plan on going anywhere.
Uh, this coming year, we're going to
have a released 10 million step per
second stable RL with a huge amount of
visibility. We got some pretty cool
algorithmic improvements planned as
well.
I think that this coming year will be
the year that you start to see ARL
working out of the box on medium-siz
problems that would take us like minimum
a month or two of work right now with
the current tools. So I think that's the
level of improvement we're looking for
this coming year.
For everybody who's been tuning in,
all my stuff's here at puffer.ai. Please
guard the puffer. Start the GitHub. Feed
him a star. It helps a lot. Uh, you can
join us on Discord to get involved with
development. And you can follow me on X
for more RL content. I'm going to try to
be more chill this year and not engage
so much with just the ridiculous X cycle
of [ __ ] and just like post more good
technical content. Um, and kind of just
get this field to where it needs to be.
We'll see how successful I am with that.
But anyways, thanks everyone and happy
new